In an alternative universe.
I think Bibi would be a superhero.
She'd be able to fly.
Maybe not well, because
her balance isn’t great.
Maybe like reading people's minds?
She would be wearing something
definitely with a cape.
And especially when she was flying.
I think it would be quite beautiful.
[Chuckles] Sorry.
The color of her costume
would be a purple costume.
It's royal, it's regal,
and she's a bit of a queen.
Her name would be Bad B*tch Bibi.
I see Bibi fighting the male patriarchy.
I think Ruben, her son,
would be an excellent sidekick.
He would charm his way out of
a lot of uncomfortable situations.
But yes, I feel like they would be
a superhero fighting crime and men
dream team.
If we were to put Grace
in an alternate reality,
I would have her as liberated
as she could possibly be.
She would be madly in love with
the kindest, most gorgeous, generous man.
And she would never be ashamed of herself.
At the same time,
can you imagine if
she ran a huge charity?
Maybe she'd be like a
surprising eco warrior.
She has this massive, big, empty hole
that needs to be filled
with people who have
a fire in their belly,
so that she gets one too.
I think the Garvey girls
cannot live too far apart.
There's a huge love magnet
That just summons them all together
In whatever universe,
there will always be the invisible string
that keeps them together.